this morning was a very tragic one for
us
two cruise missiles hit haruki
the city
which is located to the borders of the
russian federation there were always
many russians there
and they're always friendly there were
warm relations there
more than 20 universities are there
it's the city that has the largest
number of universities in our country
the youth is bright smart there
the people who gathered there all the
time and was gathering there all the
time for celebrating all the
celebrations at on the largest square in
our country the
freedom square
and this is the largest square in europe
and that's true this is called the
freedom square can you imagine this
morning two cruise missiles
hit this freedom square
dozens of
killed
ones this is the price of freedom
we are fighting
just for our land
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country and believe you me
every square
of today no matter what it's called
it's going to be called
as today freedom square
in every city of our country
nobody's gonna break us
we're strong
we're ukrainians
we have
a desire to see our children
again and again president putin is going
to say that is some kind of operation
and we are heating a military
infrastructure where our children what
kind of military factories do they work
at
what tanks are they going with or
launching cruise missiles he killed 16
people just yesterday
to be
equal members
of europe
i believe that
today
are showing everybody that's exactly
what we are
you the european union
is going to be much stronger with that
so that's for sure
without you
ukraine
is going to be lonely
we have proven our strengths
we have proven
that
as at a minimum
we are exactly
the same as you are
so do prove that you are with us
do prove
that
you will not let us go
do proof that you indeed are europeans
and then
life will
win over death and light will win over
darkness glory be to ukraine